IT'S BEEN A VERY CRAZY WEEK
FOR THE NCAA A WEEK, THAT I
DON'T THINK
WILL FULLY APPRECIATE THE
RAMIFICATIONS OF
FOR A WHILE
I BEGAN ON MONDAY WITH THE US
SUPREME COURT,
MAKING IT CLEAR THAT THE
BUSINESS MODEL IS AN ANTITRUST
VIOLATION. IT IS A WALKING
TALKING BREATHING,
CRAPPING ANTITRUST VIOLATION.
AND YESTERDAY, THERE WAS
ANOTHER
COURT RULING IN A CASE
INVOLVING,
I THINK A SWIMMER FROM ARIZONA
STATE AND A FEMALE BASKETBALL
PLAYER FROM OREGON
THAT THAT JUST
FURTHER
SCORES THAT THE
CHANGING FOR THE NCAA
AND THE BIGGEST CHALLENGE
RIGHT NOW, THE NAME
IMAGE AND LIKENESS
RULES THAT THE NCAA IS
SCRAMBLING TO DEAL WITH.
BECAUSE THE WHOLE THAT THE
WHOLE IDEA
THAT
PLAYERS CANNOT
GENERATE REVENUE
FROM THE FAME THAT
THEY HAVE
REALIZED, WHETHER IT'S PLAYING
COLLEGE SPORTS OR HIGH SCHOOL
OR WHATEVER ELSE TICK-TOCK
WHEREVER THEY'VE BECOME
FAMOUS, YOU CAN'T MAKE ANY
MONEY FROM THAT
THAT HAS TO GO AWAY. THAT
THAT THAT IS JUST THE
EXTRA LITTLE THING. THE NCAA
A DOES TO BOOST UP THIS GOOFY
NOTION OF AMATEUR
ATHLETIC SO NOBODY CAN MAKE
ANY MONEY
AND THE LONGER THEY DELAY.
THIS BIG CAT
THE, THE MORE EXPENSIVE IT'S
GOING TO BE
THE GREATER THAT THE
FINAL VERDICT IS GOING TO BE
IN THE CLASS ACTION LAWSUIT.
AND THEY ARE REALLY STUCK HERE
AND I THINK THEY'RE JUST
COMING TO TERMS WITH THE IDEA
WE'VE GOT OPEN THE FLOODGATES
AND LET ALL THESE ATHLETES,
GO OUT AND MAKE WHATEVER MONEY
THEY CAN MAKE OFF OF
THEIR NAME, THEIR IMAGE AND
THEIR LIKENESS AND THAT'S ALL
COMING. NEXT THURSDAY,
ONE
DAY BEFORE ARE
ROGERS OPS OUT FOR THE ENTIRE
SEES. SO IS EVERYONE GETTING
PAID NEXT YEAR? EXPLAIN THAT
TO ME MIKE LIKE I'M FIVE YEARS
OLD BECAUSE I'M OBVIOUSLY
THANK YOU FOR
JUST A WEEK.
I WAS GETTING PAID NEXT WEEK.
I THINK, AS OF JULY 1
I THINK THAT'S WHAT JULY 1
ONCE. ONCE THEY
WAIVE THAT FLIGHT, IS IT THE
CHECKERED FLAG OR THE WHITE
FLAG? WHAT'S THE FLAG TO START
THE RACE? IS IT A WHITE FLAG?
ONCE THEY WAVE THE FLAG TO
START THE RACE NEXT THURSDAY?
THURSDAY
GREEN FLAG. IT'S A GREEN FLAG.
ALL RIGHT, GREEN
FLAG. ONCE A RAVE.
WAVED THE GREEN FLAG, NEXT
THURSDAY,
ANYONE CAN DO BUSINESS
WITH ANYONE ELSE
AND THIS IS THE WAY IT'S
MOVING. THERE ARE SIX STATES
THAT ARE MAKING NAME IMAGE AND
LIKENESS RULES
EFFECTIVE NEXT WEEK. THE NCAA
IS REALIZING THE LONGER
WE TELL
THESE KIDS. THEY CAN'T DO IT
THE MORE
LIABILITY, WE'RE GOING TO BE
EXPOSED TO AFTER THIS AT
SUPREME COURT. RULING THAT
SHOWS THE WHOLE THING'S. AN
ANTITRUST VIOLATION. ALL THESE
RULES
THAT TELL SCHOOLS WHAT THEY
CAN'T DO BY WAY OF
GIVING.
IS BENEFITS OR LETTING THEM
MAKE MONEY FROM THEIR FAME, IS
AN ANTITRUST VIOLATION, ALL
THESE DIFFERENT UNIVERSITIES
COMING TOGETHER AND AGREEING.
WE'RE, YOU KNOW, WE'RE GOING,
WE'RE GOING TO FIX THE PRICE
OF OUR LABOR. THAT'S BASICALLY
THE ARGUMENT. SO IT'S THE
FLOODGATES OPEN NEXT. NEXT
THURSDAY, I HAVEN'T SAID ARCH
MANNING IF HE WANTS TO, IF,
YOU KNOW UNCLE PEYTON DECIDES
TO TAKE HIM UNDER HIS WING AND
SHOW HIM A FEW THINGS ABOUT
BUSINESS ARCH, MANNING CAN
START SELLING JERSEYS, PUT
HIS FACE ON THINGS POSTERS
WHATEVER AUTOGRAPH,
APPEARANCES, YOU CAN MAKE
MONEY, HOWEVER, YOU
SEE FIT IT.
FREE ENTERPRISE AS OF NEXT
THURSDAY, SUBJECT TO SIDE,
I'M SURE THERE WILL BE SOME
EFFORT TO APPLY
RULES AND RESTRICTIONS AND
MAYBE PROTECT PEOPLE FROM
CHARLATANS.
BUT WHY NOT?
LOOK IT'S WHY NOT.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF HOW?
THINK OF HOW BIZARRE IT IS
THAT LETS SAY, IF YOU'RE
17 YEARS OLD AND YOU'RE AN
ACTOR OR A SINGER OR
SOME OTHER CELEBRITY YOU CAN
MAKE AS MUCH MONEY AS YOU
WANT. HOWEVER, YOU WANT OFF
OF ANYONE WHO WANTS TO DO
BUSINESS WITH YOU
TO LEVERAGE
YOUR FAME INTO REVENUE.
WHY HAS IT EVER BEEN?
BEEN THAT?
JUST BECAUSE YOU PLAY A SPORT
AND YOUR FAME DERIVES FROM
THAT THAT YOU'RE NOT ALLOWED
TO DO IT IS RIDICULOUS WHEN
YOU THINK ABOUT IT?
YEAH. NO. IT'S BEEN
RIDICULOUS. FOR VERY LONG
TIME. THERE'S VERY FEW PEOPLE
THAT STAND ON THE OTHER SIDE,
BEING LIKE, HEY, THIS IS,
THIS IS BAD.
THIS IS BAD FOR THE KIDS. I
THINK THERE'S LIKE MAYBE FOUR
PEOPLE LEFT.
BUT I GUESS
I DON'T
UNDERSTAND HOW THEY'RE GOING
TO
KEEP THE RULES.
THERE, BECAUSE
FROM WHAT YOU JUST SAID TO ME,
THE LIGHT BULB WENT OFF IN MY
HEAD
THAT,
YOU KNOW, IF
PENN NATIONAL STOCK GOES
THROUGH THE ROOF
SOMEDAY, I WILL BE
HIRING A BUNCH OF
INTERNS THAT HAPPEN TO
BE
FIVE-STAR RECRUITS
WHO WANT TO PLAY AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF WISCONSIN. IS
THAT WHAT YOU'RE SAYING TO ME?
BECAUSE I AM DOWN FOR
THAT.
I THINK LET ME TAKE IT EVEN A
STEP FARTHER THAN THAT
BECAUSE
ONE THING THAT DAWNED ON ME,
THIS
JAKE. NOW LOOK, THIS IS ALL
SUBJECT TO WHATEVER RULES GET
PUT IN PLACE AND
THE NCAA WANTS CONGRESS.
DESPERATELY TO COME IN AND
CREATE A NATIONWIDE
STANDARD. SO THE NCAA CAN SAY,
HEY WE ALL HAVE ANYTHING TO DO
WITH, IT'S NOT AN ANTITRUST
VIOLATION.
IF CONGRESS SAYS THESE ARE THE
RULES BUT
WHAT WHY
WOULD
A
17 18, 19
YEAR OLD ATHLETE BE PROHIBITED
IN A STATE WHERE
GAMBLING IS LEGAL
FROM DOING AN ENDORSEMENT DEAL
WITH A SPORTS BOOK.
WHAT'S WRONG WITH THAT? NOW IN
THE NFL YOU CAN'T DO IT
BECAUSE THE ANTITRUST
VIOLATIONS DISAPPEAR UNDER THE
COVER OF THE
UNION RELATIONSHIP, THE NFL
CAN HAVE RULES
WITHOUT CREATING AN ANTITRUST
PROBLEM BY SAYING
PLAYERS AREN'T ALLOWED TO DO A
DEAL WITH
DRAFTKINGS AND FANDUEL POINTS.
BET PENN NATIONAL,
WHOEVER
YOU OPEN THESE NI L
FLOODGATES, YOU DON'T HAVE TO,
EVEN YOU'LL HAVE TO MAKE UP A
PHONY JOB.
YOU CAN JUST SAY, HEY, YEAH,
KIDS GOING TO WISCONSIN. HE'S
GOING TO BE AN AMBASSADOR
GREAT FOR THE
PAIN NATIONAL BRAND AND I'M
PAYING HIM A HUNDRED GRAND A
YEAR.
I LOVE THIS. I WANT TO
BE A BOOSTER, MIKE, I REALLY
DO
SOMEWHAT SHADY BOOSTER. I
REALLY,
I'M ACTUALLY A LITTLE,
THE DOWNSIDE
I KIND OF WANTED TO BE A SHADY
BOOSTER.
I WANTED TO BE
BOOSTING IT IN AND, YOU
KNOW, HAVE IT BE A BIG THING
THAT BLOWS UP IN MY FACE.
I THINK THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN
FUN. IT WOULD HAVE BEEN A FUN
CHAPTER IN MY LIFE. NOW IT
SOUNDS LIKE I CAN DO THIS ALL
ABOVE BOARD ABOVE THE TABLE
OF LEGALLY. YEAH. LIKE SO
I DON'T KNOW. I'M ACTUALLY A
LITTLE BUMMED I THINK I'M ON
THE SIDE OF
THESE RULES. KIND OF THINK
NOW.
HEY, YOU KNOW WHAT? THERE'S
SOME THERE'S SOME
TRUTH EMBEDDED IN THIS THAT I
THINK IS GOING TO
WORK TO THE DISADVANTAGE
OF THE
WISCONSIN'S AND THE WEST
VIRGINIA'S OF THE WORLD.
BECAUSE WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN
NOW
THOSE TWO THINGS ARE NOT
FIGURE OUT HOW TO
THOSE TWO THINGS ARE, NO, BUT
IT'S
BUT, BUT WAIT, IS CHICAGO
IN WISCONSIN NOW, I MEAN,
NO, BUT I'M JUST SAYING.
GOES TO THOSE TWO THINGS
AREN'T THE SAME, BUT HERE'S
GO, HERE'S MY POINT. HERE'S
MY, HERE'S MY POINT.
THE
ADVERSITIES
THAT HAVE THE LARGEST
CONCENTRATION
OF SUPPORTERS
BOOSTERS?
REALLY RICH PEOPLE WHO WILL
GLADLY TAKE THE TAX
WRITE-OFF UNDER THE GUISE OF
DOING A BAD DEAL.
A BAD ENDORSEMENT DEAL.
HEY, I GOT MY CAR DEALERSHIP
AND THE QUARTERBACK OF THE
FOOTBALL TEAM IS GOING TO
HAVE HIS FACE ON EVERY
AD THAT I DO. AND I'M GOING TO
PAY HIM 500 GRAND,
EVEN THOUGH THAT IS A
HORRIBLE
USE OF MY MARKETING
BUDGET.
DON'T CARE. MY POINT IS
FOR THE
UNIVERSITIES THAT HAVE
MORE PEOPLE
BIGGER
POPULATION CENTER MORE OF
THESE BOOSTERS FLOATING
AROUND WHO ARE WILLING TO DO
BAD BUSINESS DEALS,
THOSE SCHOOLS ARE GOING TO
BECOME MORE ATTRACTIVE BECAUSE
THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE MORE
RESOURCES
THROUGH
THERE. NO LONGER SHADY
BOOSTERS NOW YOU COULD ARGUE
WELL, OKAY, YOU KNOW, THE
THAT THEY SHOULD HAVE BEEN
PROFITING ALL ALONG BECAUSE
THEY CAN HAVE MORE SHADY
BOOSTERS. I THINK IT CHANGES
WHEN IT'S ALL ABOVE BOARD
AND YOU CAN GO OUT AND RECRUIT
YOUR BOOTH.
ESTHER'S TO
TO GET INTO THIS KIND OF
BUSINESS AND ESSENTIALLY
FUNNEL MONEY TO THE PLAYERS
AND AND LOOK THERE'S GOING TO
HAVE TO BE A SUBTLETY TO IT
BUT IT'S GOING TO CHANGE
EVERYTHING.
IT REALLY IS GOING TO CHANGE
EVERYTHING
WHEREVER IT GOES.
HOWEVER IT GOES. IT'S NOT
GOING TO KILL
COLLEGE FOOTBALL BUT IT'S
DEFINITELY GOING TO CHANGE IT.
IT'S NOT NOTHING CAN KILL
COLLEGE FOOTBALL.
IT WON'T BE WON'T DIE BECAUSE
THE TRADITION AND THE HISTORY
AND
THE AMOUNT OF PEOPLE THAT CARE
ABOUT IT. IT'S ALWAYS GOING TO
BE THERE
IN SOME IT.
PATIENT.
IT'S FUNNY THAT YOU SAY ALL
THAT BECAUSE THEN
IMAGINE LIKE IN 20 YEARS,
YALE WINS A NATIONAL TITLE
HEEL BEATS ALABAMA. BECAUSE IF
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT JUST
PURE, YOU KNOW MONEY.
DONORS. ALL THESE THINGS
WOULDN'T THAT WOULDN'T YOU
THEN SAY THAT THE IVY LEAGUE'S
ARE NOW GOING TO BE WE'RE
GOING TO GO BACK IN TIME,
IT'S GOING TO BASICALLY BE
THE TURN OF
CENTURY. NOT THIS TURN IS
CENTURY, BUT THE ONE BEFORE
WE 1900 AND IT'S GOING TO BE,
IT'S GOING TO BE HARVARD VERSE
YALE, FOR THE NATIONAL TITLE.
WELL,
NO,
I MEAN
I MEAN YOU JUST SAID YOU JUST
SAID
THE MOST OF THE TEAM'S, YOU
KNOW, THE MOST ATTRACTIVE
TEAMS WILL BE THE ALUMNI WITH
THE MOST MONEY.
THOSE
AN IVY LEAGUE, ALUMNI, AND THE
ENDOWMENT THAT THEY HAVE IS
OFF THE CHARTS COMPARED TO
ANYWHERE ELSE, RIGHT?
LET ME, LET ME JUST SAY THIS
FROM THE PERSPECTIVE OF
SOMEONE WHO TRIED TO GET INTO
AN IVY LEAGUE LAW, SCHOOL AND
FAILED, 30-PLUS YEARS AGO,
YOU GOT TO BE ABLE TO BE
TO BE, YOU KNOW,
ELIGIBLE TO GO TO THE SCHOOL.
THERE AREN'T MANY PEOPLE
SMART ENOUGH TO GET INTO THE
IVY LEAGUE SCHOOLS, SO
I THINK THAT REDUCES THE
UNIVERSE OF GUYS THAT
YOU'RE GOING TO GET THERE, NO
MATTER WHAT IN THIS DAY AND
AGE,
PLAIN AND SIMPLE.
SO
AND AND ALSO I DON'T KNOW THAT
THE HARVARD AND YALE
GRADS OUT THERE WITH
A LOT OF MONEY ARE GOING TO BE
WILLING TO START PEELING OFF
HUNDRED GRAND HERE IN A
HUNDRED GRAND THERE TO BOOF UP
TO BEEF UP THE
FOOTBALL BASKETBALL TEAMS. BUT
I
WHAT WILL BE DEAD IN THE
GROUND BY THE TIME IT HAPPENS,
BUT MAYBE OUR KIDS
AND GRANDKIDS WILL
REALIZE THAT INSTEAD OF
CLEMSON
AND ALABAMA IT'LL BE HARVARD
AND YALE EVERY YEAR IN THE
NCAA CHAMPIONSHIP. YEAH,
I MEAN IT'S
THE WAY YOU DESCRIBED IT. IF
I DON'T THINK THAT'S OBVIOUSLY
GOING TO HAPPEN BUT IT
IS AN INTERESTING DYNAMIC THAT
LIKE THE ALUMNI
OF WHERE DID, WHERE DID JEFF
BEZOS GO TO COLLEGE? DID HE GO
TO COLLEGE? WE NEED TO FIGURE
THAT OUT. HE WENT TO
WISCONSIN. I THINK I DON'T
KNOW. I FEEL LIKE HE WAS ONE
OF THOSE GUYS WHO DROPPED OUT
LIKE
LIKE THAT.
KNIT KNIT. WHAT DOES IT SAY
ABOUT THE COLLEGE SYSTEM THAT
THE MOST RIDICULOUSLY
SUCCESSFUL PEOPLE IN SOCIETY?
ALL REALIZED AT SOME POINT
DURING THAT FOUR-YEAR PERIOD,
I'M GETTING THE HELL OUT OF
HERE.
I'VE JUST, YOU KNOW, FOOD FOR
THOUGHT SOUNDS LIKE THEY
DIDN'T HAVE FUN
IN COLLEGE. YEAH, THAT'S WHAT
IT SOUNDS LIKE TO ME
HAVING FUN NOW. O FRIGGIN A ROC
TO